うん
緊張するいつものポスターが入ったこの部屋にはこれあげたーちまんだよコニーちゃん
肇社長です
[拍手]
お久しぶりですね
やっぱもうねなんかあの動画を取る感覚を忘れて戸惑うね非常に泊まるんですけども
まぁ今日の動画で僕が何を言いたいかといいますと
まあ1か月半では休んでたんですけどもどうぞを吸収していて1か月半の中でも
いろんなことがありますか
めちゃの皆さんは休止中内の北何してるかたぶん気になると思うんですけど今日は僕が
救出
中だったら一回ファンの間に起きた僕が驚いたこと元金がベスト3を発表しようと思い
ますよ
アクスしてもいいのか把握することだいやめざどういうテンションでどうすればいいの
延命酢米する前むせぶぜ拍手することじゃないのはわかるがよくわかんないけど
発表するねこーよはい的で第3位まあこれは抽出いいというか復帰した瞬間だったん
ですけれども
チャンネル登録者が500万に行きましたありがとうございます
素直に喜んでいいかわかりませんんなんかなぁ
羊な気持ちですね復帰したシーンがすごいチャンネル登録させが増えて
あの
うれしい気持ちハンドランプマンな気持ち半分でございました
でも結構いろんな人が見てくださっているんだなと思って
今後も頑張っていこうと思いました本当にありがとうございます
ヤバイでしょうかとした瞬間500万には8倍台に応援してくれてる男の子たちからの
メッセージという手紙が届きましてここにあるんですけどもうちょっと見ていきます
一緒にほんとありがたいよ
サインくださいって言うんですかいてあげたいんだけどもこういうの開通とみんなに
返さなきゃいけなくなるから
が書かないんですけども直接馬場 line に送るというより事務所とかに送って
くれるとありがたいでございますわざわざありがとうに本当に youtube のん
人は辞めないでください
片頭をくださいなんか医学書なおスタートがありますねこの愛知県から手紙送ってくれ
てて食べないと欲しいから送ってくれたんだなと思って僕は重税に嬉しかったです
ありがとうございます
でもう一度生きてマウスこちらサインください始め様ここに僕がサイン書くところが
ありますね
すらちーさん
[音楽]
まあついでに育ち方いやみたいなとりあえずサインもらっとこうかなみたいな感じで
書いたんでしょうねありがとうございますまず僕のために手紙書いてくれて本当に
ありがとうございま
この手紙をヒカキンさんに届けてサインをもらってヒカキンさんにこの手紙を戻して
もらってください
ぼくんちに切ってよろしくお願いします帰りの
[音楽]
1 key さんの最高ヒカキンさんの最後が一番この書く場所が小さいっていう
ほっこりするようなことも実はあります2でいきましょう第一第5位はですねや僕も
すごいなと思いましたよ凄いと言うかねもうなんかうわーマジかっていう感じだったね
今家はこっちに置いてあるんですけども
はいここに置いてあるの全部でございますこれ何
かというと僕の住所に代引きで知らない人から荷物が届けられてほっとさんなんか頼ん
でだっけと思って軽い気持ちで受け取ったらすごい量だったんですよ散らない人から
ぱくんつ宛てにだエピレ気持ちが送られてきたのがこちらでございますすげー価格られ
てきてるんですけどもこちらですギュッと圧縮
十分対比
はいだけでこれだけの量の牛糞がだいぶ傷いたずらで送られてきました
なんだっけなのは確か4万円くらいだったと思います
[音楽]
なんで受け取ったんだろう14万円分届いて僕お金を払いました
これに関しなんですけどもこれはさすがにやべえと思って僕アマゾンに電話したんです
よ謎に電話してもうそのあの大量 dqn を送ってきた人の住所も完全に曲がって
おります多分これ僕が迷惑や僕は名んですけどね僕は迷惑なんですけど戻っつけてるど
amazon さんとか
僕が溜まってない9
の代引きでわざわざ届けば配達業者さんとかなとの人たちの方に迷惑かかっているので
武漢今回動画に撮りたいと思ったら返品せずにお金払って受け取っちゃったんですけど
ももしコレなにかというと僕から脈エフェクトより多分そちらから連絡が行くと思い
ますのでこういうことはしないで頂きたいと思っております
きた瞬間今後も来るんだろうなと思ってない美形で受け取りは全部
拒否して何か送っても僕の方に今届かないようになっておりますやー
ほんとそれぐらいです僕がかうわーってなったのはこれぐらいだったんですけれども
たまに末で誰かに見かけられたりすると始めた通り頑張って下さい復活待ってます応援
してますっていう言葉をたくさんいただけて千葉北アップ嬉しかったですはいこんな
感じで二僕の親父道は
ん
あの9分どうしよう
[音楽]
me
あっはっ